okay Bill Maher had a woman named Bella
Thorne on his podcast and I guess Bella
Thorne is uh an actress uh I don't know
but yeah she's an actress and this
exchange on the podcast is going viral
it's uh interesting though not really
for the reason that most people are
saying but let's watch
it there's a lot of Trends you know I
always see that in the paper about
somebody who has switched their sex
which I'm all if that's what makes you
that what blows your dress up all the
way
yes
bad be who you are yes claps claps makes
me happy I mean I think there's some uh
money to be made in some sort of
exchange with everyone switching where
like you know if you need a penis take a
penis if you have a penis give a penis
you know like if people are becoming
like men to women they're going to cut
off their penis and then there are women
transitioning who are going to need a
penis uh I feel like if there was some
exchange uh maybe Bitcoin could be
involved and you couldn't you
know no I just don't like joking about
oh I know that you like to but I see
this is where the oh for f what a shame
that is where you're that is you don't
have to be sorry but I'm not sorry
either and that is where your xiety
comes from there is nothing wrong with
joking nothing wrong about that it's not
everybody is that sensitive not
everybody needs to be that sensitive
even the people who are doing that I
don't think would need to be offended by
that everybody is so easily offended you
kids you wake up offended you should you
should get off Twitter get off social
media and and maybe you wouldn't like
have this anxiety this like because I
don't know if you're really offended or
you're just worried that you're going to
look
offended no I'm 100% offended like when
when I think about you know someone's
trama and someone W the videos that I
have seen that are so like so bad and
what people have to worry about walking
on the street just being themselves like
f anxiety that's why I don't like to
like joke about it because you know
someone hears it and on a public
platform is so bad because you're like
kind of key spreading like this like
oh
um first of all I think I think Bill
Mah's idea is kind of innovative and
interesting I think he's on something
you know I mean it's not it's not a
business I could get find myself uh
being involved in for um re matters of
principle but you
know yeah he's kind of take a penny
leave a penny take a penis leave a penis
this this exchange of body Parts maybe
eventually that's where where we'll end
up um
but I just want to I want to
quote uh Bella Thorn's reasoning for why
we shouldn't joke about trans people
okay because I transcribed it just to
quote what she just said there she
said I'm 100% offended like when I think
about you know someone's trauma the
videos that I've seen that are so like
so effing back
and when people have to worry about
walking on the street just being
themselves like that's effing anxiety
that's why I don't like to like joke
about it because you know someone hears
it and on a public platform it's so bad
because you're like kind of low-key
spreading like this like oh haa and it's
like it's not
funny okay that's not English I don't
know what that
is I mean it's not Spanish either it's
not
French it's not German as far as I know
it's it it's not a
language you understand that that that
is not human
language it's
not okay I'm not we won't get into the
actual topic they were
discussing because only one of them was
discussing a topic the other was
rambling incoherently now of course
she's wrong about the the idea that we
shouldn't joke about gender ideology
obviously we should joke about it but
I'm not going to dignify her by
responding to the point that we could
only assume she was trying to
make
instead I want you to think about the
fact that this is I guess a prominent
relatively prominent relatively
successful
actress and she can't speak she cannot
speak she's not the only one we have
millions of people in this country who
cannot
speak they cannot express their thoughts
through spoken
language it's a problem I'm telling you
it is a
problem this is not just um old guys
shouting at the clouds
thing it might be that too but but it's
also
true we've got now generations of
Americans who who can barely convey a
thought through
words now I know you might say oh she's
an actress of course she's stupid but
yeah go back and watch interviews with
actresses from like the 50s okay okay go
back and watch an interview with Audrey
heurn or something she could speak she
could
articulate she could
communicate even athletes and and
football players back then could
communicate everybody
could now we have this I I don't even
know what this
is actually I do know you know what this
is you know you just heard that what
Bella Thorne sounds like honestly she
sounds like someone talking in their
sleep that's what it sounds like have
you ever
heard um have you ever heard someone we
all have you hear someone talking in
their sleep and it's it's it's always
kind of a little bit a little bit
bizarre and and mumbled and jumbled and
it's disjointed and you can only sort of
vaguely understand what they're saying
and you're not in their dreams you're
kind of guessing at what the context
might be and what it is that they're
dreaming about um
and and that's how that's how people
speak now that's Bella Thor she could
have been sleeping that entire for all I
know she was actually asleep that whole
interview she could she was she could
have been in a coma for That interview
and you wouldn't there'd be no
difference Bill Mark could be sitting
there interviewing her while she is
sleeping and it would sound the
same and be just as
intelligible or unintelligible as the
case may
be and if it was just her I would say it
doesn't matter it's just Bella Thorne oh
you know oh Bella Thorne up to her old
tricks again you know Bella Thorne you
know how she acts whoever she is um but
it's not just her again this her whole
it's millions of people this is how they
they all are walking around
asleep speak unable to
project their
voices and communicate their thoughts
and ideas and their desires and and and
wants and fears like they can't
communicate
it and it's not they can communicate it
through written word
either okay if we you know if we were
just evolving to become or devolving to
become a a
nonverbal uh
species but that could still communicate
through
writing I I could live with that in fact
I might even prefer that that might that
might that wouldn't be so bad
but we can't but they can't write
either you know they they communicate
through written with they they use
pictures to
communicate so I'm telling like we are
going back
to we we are going back in time we we
are losing our capacity for human
communication and I I shudder to think
what the world will look like and sound
like even a hundred years from now can
you
imagine
what 100 more years of progressing or
regressing in that direction what in the
world I me we are going to be walking
around 100 years from
now
grunting we'll still have podcasts
there'll still be podcasts and it will
just be two people grunting at each
other hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there